Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入探讨今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造能够为你带来收益的收入，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“持续性收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. What does the British Psychological Society say that an assistant psychologist
这些原则都同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一一小时指导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。请访问我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。英国心理学会（BPS）认为助理心理学家
should be doing? What do they say they should not be doing? I am joined once again by Luke Meakin, an assistant psychologist. We are taking a look at the recent guidance put together by the BPS looking at how to recruit assistant psychologists. It is an invigorating, lively, really interesting and helpful discussion. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. It is my pleasure to bring you this close look at what goes on in the minds of qualified psychologists
应该做些什么？他们认为不应该做什么？今天再次与我同行的是助理心理学家卢克·梅金（Luke Meakin）。我们正在探讨BPS近期发布的关于如何招聘助理心理学家的指导意见。这是一场充满活力、生动有趣且极具参考价值的讨论。我希望你能从中获得满满的收获。嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我很高兴能带大家深入了解合格心理学家的内心世界，
and speaking to our guests who I have just recorded this episode with and you're just about to meet again. It just reinvigorates my passion for this podcast, it really does, that it's making a difference, that it's appreciated, that you are getting access to really important, helpful conversations that you may or may not be getting access to in your immediate work or learning environment, but that it can help shape you and your thinking and hopefully make your life working in mental health work better for you. Let's dive in and I will catch you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome back to the podcast, Luke Meakin, an assistant psychologist. Hi, Luke. Lovely to have you back.
并且刚才我才刚录完这期节目，你马上就能再次见到我们的嘉宾。这真的重新点燃了我对这个播客的热情，确实如此，因为它正在产生影响，得到了大家的认可，而且能让你接触到非常重要、有帮助的对话——这些对话你在日常的工作或学习环境中可能接触到，也可能接触不到，但它能帮助塑造你和你的思维，并有望让你的心理健康工作生活对你而言变得更好。让我们深入探讨吧，我们在节目的另一端见。嗨，我只想欢迎助理心理学家卢克·梅金再次来到播客节目中。嗨，卢克。很高兴你能回来。
Hi, Marianne. Thank you for having me back. It's a pleasure to be here again. Oh, I agree. I was like, you know, when you're preparing for a day and you sometimes think, oh, I've got to do that. Like today I was I was like oh I get to see Luke again so like it's a little stout shift isn't it like but I was really looking forward to seeing you so thank you for being here of course thank you it's great to be back and you know we're talking today again about assistant psychologists and since we met pretty much as soon as we'd met we messaged each other to say oh look there's some some guidance on the recruitment of assistant psychologists from the British Psychological Society now the BPS and obviously when we met for our audience
嗨，玛丽安。谢谢你邀请我回来。很高兴能再次来到这里。噢，我同感。我就觉得，你知道，当你为一天做准备时，有时会想，哦，我得做那个。就像今天我一直在想，哦，我又可以见到卢克了，所以这有点像心态的转变，对吧，但我真的很期待见到你，所以谢谢你来到这里。当然，谢谢你，很高兴能回来。你知道，我们今天还是要聊助理心理学家。自从我们见面后，几乎一见面我们就给对方发消息说：“哦，看，英国心理学会发布了一些关于招聘助理心理学家的指导意见。”现在，对于我们的听众来说，显然BPS是……
it was last week for us it was pretty much feels like a lifetime ago, but it was at the start of the summer. And we were looking at the Association of Clinical Psychologists guidance for assistant psychologists. So we thought it might just be a really nice idea to kind of just compare and contrast really. So we're not going to go over too much of what we've gone over before. So people, if they haven't watched the first one they might find it helpful to do that it's called what is an assistant psychologist and what do they do and if you're looking for it and it's like years since it came out it came out in october 2024 yeah i i think it was really quite um frustrating and confusing that it came out maybe one or two days after we recorded.
对我们而言那是上周的事，感觉就像过了很久一样，但那是在夏天刚开始的时候。我们当时正在研究临床心理学家协会（Association of Clinical Psychologists）针对助理心理学家的指导意见。所以我们觉得，进行一番比较和对照可能会是一个非常不错的主意。因此，我们不会过多重复之前讨论过的内容。如果大家还没有看过第一期节目，去看一下可能会很有帮助，那期节目叫做《什么是助理心理学家以及他们做什么》，如果你在找它，而且距离它发布已经过去好几年了的话——它是2024年10月发布的。是的，我觉得它在发布后的一两天内就推出，这其实相当令人沮丧和困惑。
So it is definitely good to have this time to download it this morning whilst I was eating breakfast. But I couldn't do it from my tablet because you needed to be logged in. So you needed to be a BPS member to access that. And that doesn't feel that inclusive, really. Whereas the ACP one, I think I'm I'm writing saying was just a freely available online document so if anyone is working in a service and wanted to check what the BPS guidance is and they're not a member they can't and if anybody's looking to recruit but they're not a BPS member they can't necessarily
所以今天早上吃早餐时能抽出时间下载它，绝对是一件好事。但我无法通过平板电脑下载，因为你需要登录。也就是说，你必须是BPS会员才能访问它。这让人感觉并不是那么具有包容性。而ACP的那份文件，如果我没记错的话，是一个在网上可以免费获取的文档，所以如果有人在某个医疗服务机构工作，想要查看BPS的指导意见但又不是会员，他们就无法查看；如果有人想要招聘但不是BPS会员，他们也未必能
access that readily you know they might be able to contact the BPS and see if they can get a copy but yeah that was just a little bit of a heart sink moment so it delayed my processes but also made me think about people trying to do right you know it's very tricky yeah I think you're totally right is it kind of indicative of how the BPS tend to work. In my experience, you know, as you say, they put something out that's really helpful and they limit it straight away. And the website, I don't know if you go on there often, I tend to go on there maybe once a month
轻易获取。你知道，他们或许可以联系BPS看看能否获取副本，但是的，这让人感觉有点泄气，所以这耽误了我的进度，但也让我开始思考那些试图做正确事情的人（有多难），你知道，这真的很棘手。是的，我觉得你完全说得对，这在某种程度上表明了BPS的一贯工作方式。以我的经验来看，正如你所说，他们发布了一些非常有用的东西，但马上又加上了限制。而且他们的网站——我不知道你是否经常访问，我大概一个月去一次，
or if I'm trying to search particular documents, publications. It's quite a cumbersome website, but it can be depending on the device you're using. So luckily I was at work and I was able to get into it pretty easily but I think if I was on an iPad I think you use an iPad a lot if I was on an iPad I would have struggled so it's definitely a bit of a barrier in the before the first hurdles even jump yeah I think there is something about the restrictive element of BPS so I'd signed up for a course that I'd bought through them. And it's not a cheap course. And I hadn't realized when I bought it that I only get six months access. and kind of engage with it again or watch it when you've got more headspace or when you might be at
或者当我试图搜索特定文档或出版物时才会去。这是一个相当笨重的网站，具体情况也取决于你使用的设备。所以幸运的是当时我在单位，我能够比较轻松地访问它。但如果我用的是iPad——我知道你经常用iPad——如果我用的是iPad，我肯定会遇到困难。所以，甚至在跨越第一个栏杆之前，这就已经是一个障碍了。是的，我认为BPS确实存在这种限制性的元素。我曾报名参加过一个通过他们购买的课程。那可不是一门便宜的课程。而且我买的时候并没有意识到我只有六个月的访问权限。
a different stage of your learning journey to to be able to take more from it and yeah that that was a little bit annoying in terms of access to I thought yeah yeah I found that when when applying for the extra sort of divisions the subdivisions so i think i'm a member of the clinical um psychology and um psychosis psychosis psychotic disorders i suppose and it's really really difficult to access those things on the website after paying for admission into the subdivision um like yourself like you just said if there's six months you've got access to that what if you need it in a year what if you haven't prepared enough for sort of finishing that training within the six months and you know it's it just seems like they shoot themselves in the
然后当你有了更多精力，或者当你处于学习之旅的不同阶段、能够从中汲取更多知识时，再去重新接触或观看它，就会变得很困难。是的，这在访问权限方面确实有点烦人，我想……是的，当我申请加入额外的子分部时，我也发现了这一点。所以我想我是临床心理学和……精神病学/精神病性障碍分部的成员，我猜测是这样。在支付了加入子分部的费用后，要访问网站上的这些内容真的非常非常困难。就像你刚才说的，如果你只有六个月的访问权限，如果你一年后才需要它怎么办？如果你在六个月内没有为完成那项培训做足够的准备怎么办？你知道，这看起来就像是他们在试图提高包容性、提高对这个角色的认识、并将更具体的行业理解带入心理学家的工作时，却在搬起石头砸自己的脚。
foot when they're trying to increase this inclusivity they're trying to increase awareness to the role and and bring more specific understanding from the wider industry into what psychologists do um it just it just seems a bit redundant at times but yeah let's let's try and give them the benefit of the doubt with this document i suppose absolutely so know, this isn't supposed to be an anti-BPS thing. We're just, I guess we're just being curious and compassionately critical and, you know, thinking about what we would think would be good enough, you know, in any circumstance, really, in the psychology profession. So for anyone who is just interested in our conversation or doesn't perhaps have access to Bps guidance yeah i think overall
这有时看起来有点多余，不过，好吧，让我们试着对这份文件保持一点信任吧。绝对是的。所以你知道，这并不是要反BPS。我们只是……我想我们只是出于好奇，并带有建设性的批判，并且去思考在任何情况下，在心理学专业中，我们认为怎样才算“足够好”。所以，对于任何只是对我们的对话感兴趣，或者可能无法获取BPS指导意见的人来说……是的，我觉得总的来说，
actually from first read of it i was quite pleasantly surprised but um i do think we can we can get into quite a few things here but i was pleasantly surprised with the the depth of it but i think it missed the point on a few sections which i'm i'm sure you may agree with yeah um one of my one of my latter things that upset me was I was just getting into it I mentioned it just before we hit record but I was just getting into it and I was just at the point I thought I'm quite enjoying this and I was like on page 24 or something of a 36 page document and then I flicked over the page and then it was references like it was it was done and I was like oh I feel like I needed or was expecting like a little bit more yeah I know I was the exact same and it actually really helped me this morning because I was blocking out like another hour or
从初读来看，我其实感到相当惊喜。不过，我确实认为我们可以深入探讨很多事情。我对它的深度感到惊喜，但我也觉得它在某些部分没有切中要害，我相信你也会同意这一点。是的……我最近感到比较郁闷的一点是，我刚开始进入状态——我在我们按下录音键之前刚提到过这一点——我正渐入佳境，心想：“我挺喜欢这个的。”当时大概是在一本36页的文档的第24页左右，接着我翻过一页，然后就是参考文献了，就这样结束了。当时我就想：“哦，我觉得我还需要，或者说我期望能有更多内容。”
so to read it but yeah finished so I was like okay I'm gonna have to go and talk to some patients now which is which is good it's a positive. Exactly though, but when you realise you've got a 36-page document to read, you give that the appropriate time that a document like that requires, and then obviously actually you've over-read the pudding by about a third. But that said, when I opened the document to begin with, I liked the glossary, you know, I liked terms being clear. And later on during the document, it describes what it wants assistant psychologists to be called and what it would prefer that they weren't. And actually, it makes things less ambiguous. I think it makes things a bit clearer.
是的，我完全一样。而且这今天早上实际上对我很有帮助，因为我原本空出了另外一个小时左右的时间来阅读它，但它竟然读完了。所以我当时想：“好吧，我得去和一些病人谈谈了。”这也是一件好事，很积极。确实如此。但是，当你意识到自己要读一份36页的文档时，你会为这样一份文档投入相应的时间，但显然你对内容的预期和实际情况有大约三分之一的偏差。话虽如此，当我刚打开这份文档时，我很喜欢它的词汇表，你知道的，我喜欢术语被解释得很清楚。而在文档的后面部分，它描述了它希望助理心理学家被称为什么，以及它希望他们不被称为什。实际上，这减少了歧义，我认为这让事情变得更清晰了。
So basically, they'd like them to be called assistant psychologist, assistant educational psychologist and voluntary assistant psychologist. And really, those are the only three terms that they would they would like to be seen being discussed and I think that's really helpful because it you know I mean I spend a lot of time on LinkedIn then variety of different job roles that I see people having and sometimes I'm like well they sound more qualified than me like what is that I've never heard of that and then I look and see that they've actually done their psychology degree and that's it and it's like right and so sometimes I've actually spoken to people and said um you know what what is this job title and and how did that come about and they're like well that's what our service asks us to call ourselves and I sort of it feels a little bit it feels a little bit dodgy to me and actually it does make you sound very very qualified you know it's like psychology lead or um or psychologist in charge or
基本上，他们希望这些岗位被称为助理心理学家、助理教育心理学家和志愿助理心理学家。实际上，这三个是他们希望看到的仅有的三个讨论术语。我认为这真的很有帮助，因为——你知道我的意思——我在领英（LinkedIn）上花了很多时间，看到人们担任各种不同的工作角色。有时我会想：“嗯，他们听起来比我还要资历深厚。这是什么？我从来没听说过这个。”然后我查看后发现，他们实际上只是完成了心理学学位，仅此而已，我就想：“好吧。”所以有时我实际上会和这些人交谈并问：“你知道，这个职称是什么，它是怎么来的？”他们会说：“哦，这是我们单位要求我们这样称呼自己的。”我感觉这有点……感觉有点不太靠谱。而且这确实让你听起来非常非常有资历，你知道，就像心理学主管，或者是……
something like that. And I don't know, that sounds big. So yeah, for me, just this might empower people already in what is essentially assistant psychologist role to start that conversation with their employers about actually could we look to rename me in line or rename this role it's not just about person is it in line with the guidance from the British Psychological Society. Yeah I totally agree I remember in the last episode we did we spent quite a bit of time discussing the sort of common ambiguity of the role for various reasons and I do I totally agree that it's helpful the BPS have kind of said there's there's three pathways in which we would accept govern and assistant psych and with regards to the voluntary which I'm sure we'll get into a little bit because we spoke about it last time
或者负责人心理学家之类的。我不知道，这听起来很大。所以，对那些基本上已经在从事助理心理学家角色的人来说，这可能会赋予他们权力，让他们开始与雇主进行对话，探讨实际上我们能否根据英国心理学会的指导意见，将我重新命名，或者将这个角色重新命名，而不仅仅是关于个人的问题。是的，我完全同意。我记得在我们上期节目中，我们花了不少时间讨论这个角色由于各种原因而产生的常见模糊性。我完全同意BPS划定了他们认可和管理的助理心理学的三条路径，这很有帮助。关于志愿者岗位——我确信我们会深入探讨这一点，因为我们上次聊过——
the voluntary role they do say that we don't support that. However, we acknowledge it exists. So this is our recommendation. So I think it's really, really helpful to see them sort of clamping down and being more specific for those reasons you've just stated. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, I think the honorary role is a big conversation um and we will come back to it i'm sure so i think for me it also they said that and it's to to be an assistant psychologist you need to be a a psychology graduate which obviously then gives you the graduate basis for registration i get it wrong is it gbc or gbr am i i think i had gbr and we're
对于志愿者角色，他们确实表示我们不支持这种做法。然而，我们承认它存在。所以这是我们的建议。因此，看到他们开始对这些原因进行打击并变得更加具体，这真的非常非常有帮助，正如你刚才所说的那样。是的，绝对的。是的，我认为荣誉岗位是一个很大的讨论话题，我们肯定会回过头来谈它。所以对我来说，他们还指出，要成为一名助理心理学家，你需要是一名心理学毕业生，这显然会为你提供毕业生注册基础。我没说错吧？是GBC还是GBR？我记混了吗？我想我以前有GBR，而我们
talking about gbc now are we now i've got like i get them mixed up they used to be something different so what is it and what was it i think it's gbc but I'm just checking my LinkedIn because... That's graduate basis for chartership though, isn't it? Yeah, so I have GMBPSS, which on the document, because I remember being really confused when the doctor application was asking for my titles, I was really confused. Have I got graduate basis for chartership? And apparently you do, which gives you the GMBPS but when you are at the level where you have passed through traineeship that's when you can use GBC
现在在谈论GBC，对吗？现在我把它们搞混了。它们过去是不同的东西。所以它是什么，过去又是什么？我想它是GBC，但我正在查我的领英，因为……那是特许注册毕业生基础（graduate basis for chartership），对吧？对，所以我拥有GMBPSS。因为我记得在申请博士时，当表格询问我的头衔时我真的很困惑，我当时超级困惑。我拥有特许注册毕业生基础吗？显然你是有的，这给了你GMBPS资格。但当你达到了通过培训项目的阶段时，那就是你可以使用GBC的时候了。
and then after trainee you're qualified so yeah it um for me it's it's clarifying what an assistant psychologist is and that an assistant psychologist must be a graduate um which then made me think well why are people advertising placement years as assistant psychologists posts because they ought not to be because actually that is against the bps guidance now yeah like who's leading who is it the bps is supposed to be guiding the industry and um i had a quick really quick look at some of the job applications for assistant psychologists after reading this document and whilst they're improving there's still there's still a few things that are not what the bps have advised in this um so it just begs me begs the question who is supposed to be governing whom and i don't know where this confusion is coming from um but it would it
而在培训结束后，你就合格了。所以，对我和我来说，这澄清了什么是助理心理学家，以及助理心理学家必须是毕业生这一事实。这让我想到，为什么人们会把实习年（placement year）当作助理心理学家岗位来招聘？因为他们不应该这样做，因为实际上这违反了BPS的指导意见。对吧，谁在引领谁？BPS不是应该在引领这个行业吗？在我读完这份文档后，我快速浏览了一些助理心理学家的招聘启事，虽然它们有所改善，但仍然有一些地方不符合BPS在这份文档中的建议。所以这不禁让我产生一个疑问：到底是谁在管理谁？我不知道这种困惑是从哪里来的，但
would be nice to see everything sort of in the one path like this document and students they're not assistants like you say it would be dangerous kind of for them as well as the service to be given that responsibility when they're just at university because there's a big difference in skill level and competencies and and just personal development at that point yeah and I think for me, one of the things that shone out of this guidance was, this should be a development role. And even in cases where this is a voluntary role, I almost called it honorary, but I'm going to call it voluntary from now on. Because I think
如果能看到所有事情都像这份文档一样走上同一条正轨，那会很好。还有学生，他们不是助理。正如你所说，让他们在还在上大学时就被赋予这种责任，对他们和机构来说都是危险的，因为在那一点上，技能水平、能力以及个人发展都存在巨大差异。是的，在我看来，这份指导意见中闪光的一点是：这应该是一个发展性的角色。甚至在某些情况下，这是一个志愿者角色——我刚才差点叫它“名誉”岗位，但我从现在开始要叫它“志愿者”岗位。因为我认为
honorary makes the company feel better about it, and perhaps makes the person feel better as well but it is a voluntary role and it said that it should be no more than basically one day a week volunteering whole time equivalent and that there should still be the same amount of requirements for supervision and that there should still be kind of job plans and progression happening as part of that role and you know you should still have a right to accrue toil obviously not paid time off but if you're doing over and above the time that the service have said they want you for you can take that time back and that you still have rights to unpaid annual leave and yeah for me that really
“名誉”会让公司感觉好受一些，也许也会让当事人感觉好受一些，但这确实是一个志愿者岗位，并且上面说，基本上它不应该超过全职当量（WTE）每周一天，而且对于监督的要求应该保持不变，并且该角色仍应包含工作计划和职业发展。你知道，你仍然应该有权累积加班调休（TOIL）——显然不是带薪休假，但如果你做的工作超出了单位要求的时间，你可以把时间补回来——而且你仍然有权享受无薪年假。是的，对我来说，这真的
made me think about when I've been in services where there have been voluntary members of staff that sometimes it might just be like oh um oh so and so's not here tomorrow because they're on annual leave perhaps we could ask the honoree to come in with the natural fact that's not okay you know it probably never was, well it never was, but this firms that up more. This isn't just a supernumerary member of staff like you might have on an NHS ward to meet minimum numbers. This is a voluntary member of staff who cannot be counted in the numbers and actually there was even questions raised about whether a voluntary member of staff is definitely covered on the organisation's indemnity and that
让我想起我曾经呆过的那些有志愿者员工的服务机构。有时可能会出现这种情况：“哦，某某明天不来，因为他们休年假了，也许我们可以请名誉员工过来。”但事实上，这并不可以，你知道，这可能从来都不是……好吧，它从来都不是（可以的），但这一点现在得到了进一步的明确。这并不是那种你为了满足最低人员配置而在NHS病房里可能会有的超额编制员工。这是一位不能被算在编制内的志愿者员工。事实上，甚至有人提出疑问：组织机构的责任保险是否绝对涵盖了志愿者员工，
that needs to be an explicit conversation whereas in my experience this is just not the case and a voluntary member of staff has just been exploited massively basically in a nutshell yeah totally i mean i haven't been around um the honorary role but it just screams exploitation because even if all those things were put in place like well i say that i I can't see how supervision or access to supervision um would happen with a seven hour shift I think it was seven hours or seven and a half I don't see access to that purely because of the pressures on teams and services I don't see them not being given extra responsibilities that they shouldn't be doing because as you know you've worked in the NHS and you're still close to it the pressures are the pressures and unfortunately
这需要进行明确的对话。但在我的经验中，情况根本不是这样，志愿者员工基本上在很大程度上被剥削了，简而言之就是这样。是的，完全是这样。我的意思是，我没有接触过名誉岗位，但这简直就是在呼喊着“剥削”，因为即使所有这些事情都到位了——好吧，我这么说是因为我看不出在七小时（我想当时说是七小时或七个半小时）的班次里，监督或获取监督的途径是如何能够实现的。鉴于团队和服务承受的压力，我看不出他们不会被指派不应该承担的额外责任。因为正如你所知，你在NHS工作过，而且你仍然与它保持着紧密的联系，压力就是压力，而不幸的是，
often everyone has to get lumped with things they shouldn't necessarily be doing which is what we were discussing last time which is why we wanted the extra guidance which I think this is helpful for but I still just don't understand why the honorary role exists, because it's exploitative, but it also cuts off a lot of the potential workforce that couldn't get into psychology. Like myself, I'm a white male, so statistically I'm of a privileged position. I couldn't do that. I couldn't work for free for a day.
通常每个人都不得不承担他们本不该承担的事情。这就是我们上次讨论的内容，也是我们想要获得额外指导的原因。我认为这对这方面很有帮助，但我仍然不明白为什么名誉岗位会存在，因为它是剥削性的，而且它还把许多无法进入心理学领域的潜在劳动力拒之门外。就像我一样，我是一个白人男性，所以从统计学上讲我处于特权地位。我做不到这一点。我无法免费工作一天。
So it must be cutting off a lot of people. So I don't see why the need exists still. And maybe you know more about that from a managerial service development point of view, NHS, why it would still continue existing. I don't know if you could speak upon that with the pressures as to why the role may exist still. I think it's because it's condoned because it's been established as a viable way of plugging service gaps. And there hasn't been enough of a stand against it. And actually, if I was still working in the NHS NHS I think I would be part of that stand I cannot ethically get behind asking people to work for free I can't I can't hold interviews for who gets the privilege of of coming to work with me for free and and paying um you know for their parking and their commuting costs and their lunch money and all of that.
所以这一定把很多人挡在了门外。因此，我不明白为什么这种需求仍然存在。也许你从管理层、服务发展、NHS的角度对此了解更多，知道为什么它会继续存在。我不知道你是否可以结合这些压力谈谈为什么这个角色可能依然存在。我认为这是因为它被默许了，因为它已经被确立为填补服务空白的一种可行方式。而且没有发出足够的反对声音。事实上，如果我还在NHS工作，我想我会成为反对声音的一部分。我无法在道德上支持要求人们免费工作。我做不到。我无法为主持面试以决定谁才有特权
So actually they're out of pocket. So I think hopefully this guidance and the ACP guidance before it starts to, and this podcast maybe too, starts to turn the tide on that a little bit yeah yeah it's good to see that they made several references throughout the document that the bps doesn't um agree with this role existing but given it exists and the pressures it exists we strongly recommend xyz so maybe that as you say is a start in the right direction and hopefully that gives people the platform to talk more about it such as this podcast and hopefully one day pretty soon we can get rid of it because I just I don't see the positives in it really and I think especially because there's
免费来和我工作、还要自己支付停车费、通勤费和午餐费等等的人进行面试。所以实际上他们是在贴钱。因此，我希望这份指导意见以及之前的ACP指导意见开始，或许这个播客也能开始，稍微扭转一下这种局面。是的，很高兴看到他们在整篇文档中多次提到BPS不同意这个角色的存在，但鉴于它存在以及它所承受的压力，我们强烈建议“X、Y、Z”。所以正如你所说，这可能是一个朝着正确方向迈出的开始，希望这能为人们提供一个更多地讨论它的平台，就像这个播客一样，希望有朝一日很快我们就能废除它，因为我真的看不出它有什么积极意义。而且我认为，尤其是因为
lots of mentions across the the guidance around equality diversity and inclusion and trying to kind of think about contextual factors, you know, they are recognising just how inaccessible the profession can be. And so to add that further tier of voluntary roles, you know, I was reading it thinking, if I've done a voluntary placement year, and I'm legally allowed to say that that was an assistant psychologist post and put that I've worked for nine months, whole time equivalent as an assistant psychologist, I'm going to have a significant advantage in gaining interviews for paid assistant roles um yeah just i think if you're not allowed to do that then you'd have to call yourself a psychology worker i don't know just a placement student like what would you call yourself in those circumstances because in my experience everybody tends to call themselves an assistant psychologist. Yeah, yeah, you're right. I've come across psychology assistants in, I suppose that was more private healthcare.
整篇指导意见中多次提到平等、多样性和包容性，并试图去考虑语境因素，你知道的，他们正在认识到这个行业可能会是多么的难以进入。因此，再加上那层志愿者岗位，你知道，当我阅读它时我想：如果我完成了一个志愿者实习年，并且我在法律上有权说那是一个助理心理学家岗位，并把我在那里的九个月全职当量工作经历写成助理心理学家，那么我在争取带薪助理岗位的面试机会时就会有显著的优势。嗯，是的，只是……我想如果你不被允许这样做，你就必须称自己为心理学工作者。我不知道，就像一个实习生一样——在这种情况下你会称自己为什么？因为根据我的经验，每个人往往都自称为助理心理学家。是的，是的，你说得对。我遇到过心理学助理——我想这更多是在私立医疗机构中。
And they appeared sort of like half the role of an assistant psychologist, but that was used interchangeably over there. So I honestly don't know what you could be referred to as. And as you said, honorary is like a more positive spin. It's not an honorary position, is it? An honorary position is usually used for quite senior people, maybe in academic institutions. This definitely isn't that. It feels and seems like exploitative,
他们的工作职责似乎只相当于助理心理学家的一半，但在那里这两个词是可以互换使用的。所以我老实说不知道你会被称为什么。正如你所说，“名誉”是一个更具积极色彩的词。这不是一个名誉职位，对吧？名誉职位通常用于相当高级的人员，可能在学术机构中。这绝对不是那种情况。这感觉像是剥削性的，
potentially grunt work where they shouldn't be doing that at all yeah and regardless of whether someone is voluntary or um paid you know they should be assisting with it with the work of at least one practitioner psychologist and i think sometimes that is just not the case is it sometimes these posts as we spoke about last time are advertised and the practitioner psychologist doesn't even work in the service that supervises them it's kind of super remote they might even only have one contact hour a week and that is not that is not a safe service and that is not an assistant psychologist role as this guidance understands it yeah yeah totally i don't know how you could achieve those things in one day and just as you were saying that i was just having a quick look back over the the guidance
潜在的粗重杂活，而他们根本不应该做这些。是的，而且无论一个人是志愿者还是带薪的，你知道，他们都应该协助至少一位执业心理学家的工作。我认为有时事实并非如此，对吧？正如我们上次所讨论的，有时这些岗位的招聘广告中，执业心理学家甚至不在监督他们的服务机构工作，他们是超级远程的，可能每周只有一个接触小时。这不是一个安全的服务机构，也不是这份指导意见所理解的助理心理学家角色。是的，完全赞同。我不知道你怎么能在一天的之内实现这些。就在你这么说的时候，我快速浏览了一下这份指导意见，
and i've come to the job descriptions and person specifications and if you don't mind, I'll just read out the paragraph I highlighted. AP duties should broadly align with those held by a practitioner psychologist, like you mentioned, but they should be at a level proportionate to the nature of the role, should exclude management responsibilities, and should include increased supervision. So right there, that is at odds with the honorary and at least anecdotally with people I know who've worked in assistant roles they haven't achieved that. They should not be asked to take on roles that are significantly distinct
我翻到了职位描述和个人规格（person specifications）部分。如果你不介意的话，我把划线的那段读出来：助理心理学家的职责应该大致与执业心理学家的职责相一致（就像你提到过的），但它们的水平应当与角色的性质相称，应当排除管理职责，并且应当包括更多的监督。所以就在那里，这与名誉岗位是相冲突的，而且至少根据我所了解的从事助理岗位的熟人们的经验，他们并没有实现这一点。他们不应该被要求承担与典型执业心理学家角色明显不同的职责，不应该与非心理学家的职责（例如医疗保健助理角色）轮换或结合，或者主要从事行政工作。然后它接着建议，身体约束不应作为助理心理学家工作职责的一部分，这可能是一个单独的话题，但看到这一点真的很有帮助。
from typical practitioner psychologist roles that rotate with or are combined with non-psychologist responsibilities e.g. healthcare assistant roles which we've kind of just alluded to that could happen or are primarily administrative and then it goes on to recommend physical restraint is not part of the AP job role which may be a separate conversation but I think is really helpful to see that there absolutely I'd considered that paragraph as well and I don't know for me if you're working in an inpatient secure facility restraint is potentially everybody's role you know it's tricky I think if there's a core staff of nursing staff available to do it then that makes most appropriate sense but if you are there and there is severe harm happening to somebody you can't really say i'm not doing that because I'm an assistant psychologist can you? No I think I think you're right having worked in acute settings and I'm sure you have yourself
绝对的。我也考虑过那段话。而且对我来说，如果你在一个住院精神安全机构工作，约束可能是每个人的职责，你知道，这很棘手。我认为，如果有核心护理人员团队可以做到这一点，那是最为合理的。但如果你在那里，且某人正在遭受严重伤害，你不能真的说“我不会做那个，因为我是助理心理学家”，对吧？不，我想你是对的。在急性病房工作过——我确信你也有过类似的经历，你曾经接触过它们——是的，你绝对希望那里有一个配备合理、人手充足的临床团队。而且我想，当我来到目前的岗位——即成人康复服务机构时，这对我很有帮助。我对这一点也有类似的疑问，因为这里的环境类似于急性病房。它不具备相同的高度安全性，但性质相似。这让我想起了我在急性病房担任医疗保健助理的时光，当时我们会进行干预，而给出的建议是，包括心理学在内的治疗团队不应该参与干预，因为这会切断治疗关系，或者说可能会切断治疗关系。在此之前，我其实并没有真正思考过这一点。我认为这是一个极好的建议，
been around them yeah you would definitely hope there is a reasonably well staffed clinical team there and I suppose it was helpful for me when I came into my current setting, which is adult rehab services. I had similar questions about that because the environment is similar to an acute ward. It's not the same high security, but it's similar in nature. And it kind of made me think of my time on acute wards when I was a healthcare assistant and we would be responding and the advice was sort of the therapy team which psychology is included under shouldn't be responding because it severs that therapeutic relationship or potentially severs which until that moment I hadn't really thought of that I thought that was a great piece of advice
因为我们的看法略有不同，并且应该对助理心理学家角色有所贡献。我们被视为临床团队的一个额外部分，但根据我们所服务的群体，也会有所不同。我们可以更接近他们，我们拥有学位的额外知识，而且我们希望还能得到专业或临床合格人员的监督，我们不想损害那种治疗关系。然而，说到你的观点，如果周围绝对没有其他人，是的，我会被期望去帮忙，而且我们也应该这样做。所以也许可以在文档中加一个星号，暗示我们正在讨论的紧急情况，也许他们应该接受过这方面的培训，并且应该有指导方针让临床团队和护理团队去应对，
because we are seen as a bit differently and supposed to kind of add to the assistant psychologist role we are seen as an extra part of the clinical team but also a little bit different depending on the population we're working with we can get a bit closer to them we have the extra knowledge of the degree but we also have hopefully supervision from a professional or clinical qualified and we don't want to damage that therapeutic relationship however to your point if there was absolutely no one else around yes we I would be expected to help out and we should so maybe there could be an asterisk on the document alluding to what we're talking about sort of emergency situations maybe they should be trained in it and guidance should be sort of let the
在绝对必要的情况下，为了应对对自己或他人的风险——因为我完全同意你的观点。太棒了。有一个地方让我非常感兴趣，无论是从合格人员的角度来看，还是从非合格人员的角度来看，那就是当他们讨论固定期限合同岗位时，理想情况下这些岗位应该至少为期12个月。而且我认为，你知道，我做过6个月的岗位，也做过9个月的岗位。所以12个月显然会很好。但同时也应该在续签或不续签前至少三个月发出通知。这让我想到，天哪，有时我离合同到期只有一周了，才得到会被留用的点头示意。所以如果能有某种东西让
clinical team respond nursing team um absolute necessary must risk to self risk to others because i totally agree with your point there yeah lovely um one bit that that made me quite interested both from a qualified perspective as well as a an unqualified perspective was when they were talking about the the fixed term roles and that ideally they ought to be for a minimum of 12 months and i think you know i've done i've done six month roles i've done nine month roles. So 12 months obviously would be great. But there also ought to be a minimum three months notice of renewals or not renewals. And that made me think, oh, gosh, sometimes I've been like a week away and got the nod that I'm being kept on. So something that makes
这一点更坚定一些，同时我也认为这能赋予人们权力去思考：“哦，我的合同还有四个月到期，我要把这个带到督导会议上，我要把它带给管理层去讨论。”因为组织机构里的车轮转动得非常缓慢，但（有了这个）它现在为你提供了那样的后盾去说……或者真的是这样吗？如果你处于一份固定期限合同中，卢克，你会觉得舒服去说“我知道我的合同还有四个月到期，而BPS的指导意见确实说过我们应该提前三个月得知消息”或者你知道，这里存在权力不对等，对吧？如果你是卢克，你会怎么想？哦，我和你一样签过固定期限合同，我完全同意你的观点。看到这一点感觉非常好，非常高兴能看到这一点，
that a little bit firmer but also I think empowers people to be able to think oh mine is four months away I'll take this to supervision I'll take this to my management um to discuss this because wheels do turn very slowly in organizations but you know it now gives you that kind of clout behind you to say um or does it because would you feel comfortable with saying i am aware we're four months away from the end of my contract and the bps guidance does say that we ought to be aware three months in advance or or you know there is that power differential isn't there how would you feel about that if you were on a fixed term contract luke oh i've been on a fixed term contract like yourself and i totally agree with you it was it was very nice to see that very pleasant to see it
但我也忍不住轻声笑了一下，心想：“哇，迈出了一大步。”因为我以前签过固定期限合同，不过幸运的是我现在签的是无固定期限合同（permanent），这真的很好。但关于你举的那个例子——去找你的经理或任何掌控这些事情的人——直属经理，“嘿，合同还有几个月就要到期了，我们能讨论一下X、Y、Z吗？”我也进行过这样的对话：“好的，好的，我们会回复的，事情会好起来的。”时间悄悄流逝，你再次进行对话：“是的，事情进展顺利。”然后我知道……我知道有类似经历的人经历过和我一样的情况，他们中的一些人甚至告诉我，他们回去找督导，督导说“是的，我们要续签”，
but also i chuckled a little bit like wow big big step because i've been on fixed terms i'm now luckily on a permanent which is really nice um but with with regards to the example you're giving approaching your manager whoever is in control of these things line manager hey contract's running out in so many months can we discuss xyz and i've had those conversations it's like yeah yeah yeah we'll get back to it things will be okay time creeps on you have the conversation again yeah things are going well and then i know i know similar people have had similar experiences to me and some of them have actually told me they've gone back to their supervisors who said yes we're going to extend
然后却被告知“不，我们不续签了”。我说：“好吧，如果真是这样的话，我只有一个月的时间去找工作了。”正如你自己所知，并且正如所有听众可能都知道的那样，工作申请、通过背景调查等流程进展得非常缓慢。所以我觉得，如果能够拿着这个去找任何负责的人并说：“看，我知道你很忙，我知道事情还没定下来。我们需要有知情权，我们需要在提前三个月收到通知。”那将是非常非常好的。
and then they were told no we're not going to extend and I said okay I've got I've got a month to find a job if that which as you know yourself and as everyone listening will probably know things move quite slowly with the job applications and getting through references and such so I think it I think it'd be really helpful to be able to take this to whoever's in charge and say, look, I know you're busy. I know things are up in the air. We have to have awareness. We have to have knowledge noticed three months before. So really, really good to see.
是的，因为你知道，这是房租。这是房贷。这是育儿费用。这是超市账单，这是支付汽车账单的能力。这些是人们的生活，你知道的。超市账单，这是支付汽车账单的能力，这些是人们的生活，你知道的。而且我认为，一旦你获得了资格，也许距离有抱负的心理学家的角度稍微远了一些，就很容易忘记这一点。
Yeah, because, you know, this is rent. This is mortgage. This is childcare. This is, you know, supermarket bills. This is being able to pay your car bills. Like this is these are people's lives, you know supermarket bills this is being able to pay your car bills like this is these are people's lives you know and I think once you get qualified and perhaps get a little bit further removed from the the kind of aspiring psychologist angle it's it's it's easier to forget that I think
这完全说得通，我想这正是我们都在追求的。但这与在最初几年不得不忍受这一点是密不可分的，某些事情我们不得不忍受，而且可能只是过时的习惯和行为，我们可以轻而易举地废除它们，所以很高兴看到这一点。是的，确实如此。这真的让我想起我为他人进行督导的时候，因为我过去一直认为我需要签署每个人的记录，因为他们当时还不具备临床责任。但这份指导意见真正表明的是，只要大家普遍遵循记录的标准，那就不再是强制必须这样做了。显然，如果有人担心
yeah that makes total sense and that's what we're all after I suppose but that kind of goes hand in hand with having to put up with this in the first few years and certain things we we have to put up with that and are probably just like outdated habits which and behaviors which we could easily do away with so it's's good to see this. Yeah, it really is. And it really made me think about when I've done supervision for people, because I actually have always thought that I needed to kind of countersign everybody's notes, because they didn't yet have clinical responsibility. But this guidance really suggests that so long as the general standard of notes is being adhered to, that's no longer necessarily enforceable. Obviously, someone was concerned about the
记录的标准，他们可能仍然会选择这样做。而且你可能会遇到一个有点控制狂倾向的人要求这样做。但实际上，这可能会很有用，你知道的，因为服务的压力——你知道，甚至为了写我自己的临床记录，我今天看了三个客户，我还没写完，我今天在我们会面后必须写完。所以，在编写我们自己的临床记录的压力面前，更不用说在周末结束前检查可能包括你的整个 caseload（病案量）的记录了，这只会让事情变得更加棘手。所以这可能会是督导中的一个有趣对话，即这不再是一个必需的要求，我们如何推进这一点，我们想对此做些什么，我们是否想探索对我们目前在服务中做事的方式做出改变？
standard of notes, they may still choose to do that. And you might get someone who is a bit of a control freak asking for that to happen. But actually, it might be useful to, you know, because of the pressures of services you know even to write my own clinical notes I've seen three clients today I haven't yet written them I've got to write them today so after we meet so in terms of the pressures of doing our own clinical notes let alone checking you know perhaps your entire caseload of notes before I finish for the week it does just make it that much trickier to do so this might be an interesting conversation in supervision that this is no longer necessarily
是的，我对这一点真的很惊讶。因为就像你一样，我当时的印象是所有东西都必须由合格人员签署。如果你是我的督导，我假设这会为你省下大量时间，或者你签署东西会花掉很多时间。但我懂的，这是最佳实践。
a requirement and how do we want to take that forward what do we want to do about that do we want to explore making changes to the way that we do things in our service currently yeah I was really surprised with that because like you, I was under the impression everything had to be countersigned by qualified. And if you were, for example, my supervisor, I assume that would free up a lot of time or you countersigning things would take a lot of time. But I get it, it's best practice.
如果出现问题，这会反映在你这位督导身上。但正如你所说，过一段时间后，我们可以在督导中讨论这一点。如果他们的标准达到了某个水平，并且85%、90%的时间都能达到那个标准，是的，这赋予了他们更多责任，
It would be reflecting on you as the supervisor should something go wrong. But as you say, after a while, we could discuss this in supervision and if they are up to a certain standard and it's like 85, 90% of the time that standard's being hit, yeah, it gives them a bit more responsibility,
赋予了我们更多责任，并腾出了那些据我所看合格人员似乎并不具备的时间。你们这些合格人员似乎没有很多时间去应付各方面的事情，你知道，我们有太多的项目，太多的盘子要转，对我们时间的总体需求也太多了。你知道，无论你是在私人诊所还是在NHS，情况绝对都是这样的。当然，NHS可能会有其自身的额外压力。我真的很喜欢关于应该如何使用督导、如何使用督导的那一部分。
gives us a bit more responsibility and frees up that time that qualifiers from what i can see just don't seem to have you guys don't seem to have a lot of time to be spread out everywhere so notice we've got too many projects too many plates spinning um but too many demands upon our time generally you know and that is absolutely the case whether you are in private practice or and it will be NHS. And of course, the NHS can have its own additional pressures. I really liked the section about how supervision should be used, how supervision could be used.
这赋予了我们更多的责任，也腾出了那些从我看来，资质较浅的人似乎并不具备的时间。你们似乎没有多少时间可以分心到各个地方，所以大家会发现我们有太多的项目，有太多的事情要应付，嗯，但是对我们时间的总需求也太多了，你知道的。无论你是在私人诊所还是在国民保健署（NHS），这绝对都是如此。当然，NHS本身也会有它额外的压力。我真的很喜欢关于应该如何使用督导、如何利用督导的那部分内容。
I thought that was quite nice to have written down. Yeah, definitely. In my personal experience, I have struggled with supervision in times in over my various roles sometimes coming in with it being sort of a bit cloudy a bit ambiguous not really knowing what it's specifically used for and then other positions it's been very specifically defined and I felt like I couldn't bring certain things into that space because they didn't meet the predetermined definition of what supervision was for. So it's really good to see this and they went into quite detail actually, quite a bit of detail. It's really good to see that it can be sort of what you and your supervisor create and with time you are building up that relationship
我觉得把这些写下来挺好的。是的，绝对是这样。就我个人而言，在我的各个岗位上，有时我会觉得督导有点模糊不清，有点含糊，不太清楚它的具体用途是什么。而在其他职位上，督导的定义非常明确，让我觉得有些事情根本无法带进那个空间，因为它们不符合督导既定的用途。所以，看到这一点真的很好，而且他们实际上写得非常详细，内容相当丰富。看到督导可以由你和你的督导共同塑造，并且随着时间的推移，你们在不断建立这种关系，这真的太棒了。
where if there is something outside the norm you bring that in and it should be it should be able to exist there and you go forward and see how it's best going to help your practice which they kept referring to supervision is to develop yourself and the supervisor to help the people you're with which is really good absolutely yeah and i loved the idea of actually using that to link your theory and your practice but also explicitly mentioning that it should you should be it stopped short of saying compassionately tested didn't it how did it phrase it um let's let me look that up and i liked the idea that it said that supervision could be used to offer AP's intellectual challenge
如果有什么超出常规的事情，你可以把它带进来，它应该、也能够在那里存在，然后你们继续探讨如何最好地帮助你的实践。他们一直提到，督导是为了发展你自己以及你的督导，以帮助你身边的人，这真的非常好。绝对是的，我也很喜欢利用这一点来将你的理论和实践联系起来，并且还明确提到它应该——差一点就说成是要经过同理心的检验了，不是吗？它是怎么表述的呢？嗯，让查查看。我喜欢它所说的督导可以用来为AP提供智力上的挑战这一观点，
enabling reflection which for me sounds like it's a compassionate challenge as well it's not like we're trying to catch you out we're trying to help you grow and develop from a respectful stance so supervision shouldn't feel like you're you're being found to be lacking like it should be you should hopefully be in your window of tolerance and well yes you should let's say that in supervision you should be within your window of tolerance let's let's go there well i'm certainly saying that um and that it shouldn't feel like you are being grilled you know that's not the intellectual challenge we're looking for like it's a it's yeah something to help transform you so that's even what they say transformational learning and psychological
从而促进反思。对我来说，这听起来也是一种充满同理心的挑战，而不是说我们试图抓住你的把柄，而是试图以一种尊重的态度帮助你成长和发展。所以督导不应该让你觉得被发现有什么不足，它应该、希望你能处于你的耐受窗口内。没错，我们可以这么说，在督导中，你应该处于你的耐受窗口内，我们就这么说吧。嗯，我确实是这么说的。而且它不应该让你觉得像是在接受严厉审讯，你知道的，那不是我们寻找的智力挑战。它是一种、没错，是能帮助你蜕变的东西，所以他们甚至提到了变革性学习和心理
support um not not just that it's you know what do you know tell us what you know yeah yeah i like the window of tolerance that's that's really helpful i i tend to use that a lot when i'm talking to service users i think it also mentioned i can't find it right now but it mentioned the zones of proximal development which is something i i tend to think of as well it's very constructive it's it's through the relationship um supervisor and the supervisee this is where you can get to with the right constructive feedback supervision is going to help you get there it might be uncomfortable at times but that's what i as a supervisor i'm here to help contain that and if you're struggling you come to me we'll figure it out together it's a it's a joint
支持。嗯，不仅仅是“你知道什么，告诉我们你知道什么”这种形式。是的，是的，我很喜欢耐受窗口这个概念，这真的很有帮助。我在跟服务对象交流时也经常使用这个概念。我想它还提到了“最近发展区”，这也是我经常会思考的一个概念。它非常具有建设性，它是通过督导和受督导者之间的这种关系来实现的。有了正确的建设性反馈，你就能达到这样的高度，而督导会帮助你到达那里。有时可能会让人感到不舒服，但作为督导，我的职责就是帮助包容这种情绪。如果你觉得挣扎，就来找我，我们一起想办法。这是一个共同的、
relationship and it's it's it's building upon what i gather those are those those foundational elements of what make a psychologist because like yourself when you are qualified you're going to be plopped in a team or in a service or run your own thing and you're going to have to be able to support staff at the same time as service users patients so it's really good to have these challenges in a safe space which I suppose is the compassionate side of things. Absolutely it should be safe and as I was hearing you talk I was thinking oh Luke's going to be a really lovely supervisor when you're qualified like because it should almost feel like a nurturing not parental but that kind
互动的关系，它建立在我所理解的那些塑造心理学家的基础元素之上。因为就像你自己一样，当你取得资质后，你会被安插进一个团队、一个服务机构，或者自己运营某个项目。你必须在支持服务对象、患者的同时，还能支持工作人员。所以，在一个安全的环境中接受这些挑战真的很好，我想这就是充满同理心的一面。绝对的，这应该是一个安全的空间。刚才听你说话时，我在想，“天哪，卢克，等你拿到资质后一定会成为一个非常好的督导。”因为这种关系几乎应该让人觉得具有滋养性——不是像父母那样，而是那种支持性的关系。
of supportive relationship it should be a little bit like get behind me i've got you like if they want you they're coming through me first um you know so that you can't be asked to do everything by everybody and nor can you be you know criticized or got at like that should feel like there's someone on your team and and kind of on your side and and yeah that that is is all about looking out for you but the um the training strategies you mentioned i'm glad you mentioned that that was page 15 i'm glad you mentioned that so that's the the use of zone of proximal development theory within supervisor supported learning which um is beinart and cloacy 2017 and when i read that i was like yeah there's use of the zone of proximal development theory and so it's okay like even at my age and stage of my
它应该有点像“站在我身后，我罩着你”的感觉。如果有人想找你麻烦，得先过我这一关。你知道的，这样你就不会被所有人要求做所有的事情，也不会受到批评或攻击。应该让你觉得团队里有人在支持你、站在你这边。而且，是的，这一切都是为了照顾好你。不过，你刚才提到的那些培训策略——我很高兴你提到了那一页，那是第15页——我很高兴你提到了这一点。这就是在督导支持的学习中运用最近发展区理论，这是Beinart和Cloacy于2017年提出的。当我读到这里时，我就想：“对啊，这里运用了最近发展区理论。”所以这没关系，即使以我这个年龄和职业阶段，
career to be like yeah don't don't really know what that is but you've sort of gone into what that is as well so thank you for covering that for our audience Luke. I'm sure you remember it might it's I think it was Vygotsky if that rings a bell it's essentially you you work at the boundary, the edge of your ability. And if you are able to work at the boundary or the edge, then you will make, with the right guidance, you will make that leap. Whereas if there is too much of a leap, say your supervisor is very, very senior, for example,
也可以说：“嗯，其实我不太清楚那是什么，”但你刚才也差不多解释了那是什么。所以谢谢你为我们的听众涵盖了这一点，卢克。我相信你还记得，这大概是维果茨基提出的，如果这听起来有些耳熟的话。本质上，你是在自己能力的边界、也就是边缘进行工作。如果你能够在边界或边缘工作，那么在正确的指导下，你就会实现跨越。然而，如果跨度太大，比如说你的督导资历非常非常深，而你又非常非常新，
and you're very, very new, that gap is too big. It's too much of a gulf. You can't access that next zone or the next ring that's how i viewed it anyway i see it's not being too overstretched it's it's what is realistic as a next step just outside of your comfort zone exactly yeah okay um just we had to take a little bit of a break in between um the first half of that reply and my second half because my little boy just got back from summer school and he came brandishing a certificate which I can't show you because it's got the name of the school on but he said I've got an award for for genuine integrity
那个差距就太大了，那是一个无法逾越的鸿沟。你无法接触到下一个区域或下一个层级——我反正一直是这么看的。我认为这并不是过度勉强，而是作为迈出舒适区之外的下一步，什么是现实可行的。完全正确，是的。好的，嗯，我们不得不在那段回答的上半部分和下半部分之间稍微休息了一下，因为我的小儿子刚从夏令校回来，他拿着一张证书，我不能向你们展示，因为上面写着学校的名字。但他对我说：“我因为表现出真正的正直而获得了奖励。”
and what was it you said? So genuine integrity is one of the school values and it means to do nice things for other people even when it's never working. Okay so don't know if you heard that but it's one of the school values is integrity but actually this award is for doing nice things for people or doing the right thing even when nobody's looking and I was like gosh isn't that isn't that what we do um in the psychology world and isn't that what we are asking for in our assistant psychologist roles as well and he's celebrating now he's kind of like he's scored a goal but that that matters doesn't it yeah that's that's brilliant first i'd say congratulations well done um it's clearly getting that from his mother uh potentially father as well i don't know but i
你刚才说什么来着？“真正的正直”是学校的价值观之一，意思即使在没人注意的时候，也要为他人做美好的事情。好吧，所以我不知道你们有没有听到，学校的价值观之一就是正直，但实际上这个奖项是颁给那些即使在没人看见的时候，也为他人做好事或做正确事情的人。当时我就想：“天哪，这不就是我们在心理学领域所做的事情吗？这不正是我们在助理心理学家岗位上所要求的品质吗？”他现在还在庆祝，感觉就像自己进了个球一样。这真的很重要，不是吗？是的，这太棒了。首先我要说，恭喜你，做得太棒了！
know he's getting it from you but yeah it's really poignant message and much of our work will be sort of behind the scenes i'm i'm in a tiny small office right now on the edge of a ward, just myself. And many assistants and qualifiers will know, you know, much of your work is spent in here preparing, looking at histories and trying to build cases. And then you go out and interact with the team or the patients. And it's good for that to be acknowledged just like your son there because it is a huge part of the role and and it's we get into it knowing that and we also want to do that we want to help others and with or without that recognition I suppose yeah and it you know
他显然是从他母亲那里继承了这一点，也许还有父亲，我不知道，但我知道他是从你这里学来的。是的，这是一个非常感人的信息。我们的很多工作其实都是在幕后进行的。我现在就在一个病房边缘的小办公室里，只有我一个人。许多助理和取得资格的心理学家都会深有体会，你知道的，你的大部分时间都是在这里度过的：备课、查阅病史、试图建立案例档案。然后你才会走出去，与团队或患者互动。能够像你儿子那样得到认可是一件很好的事情，因为这是角色中非常巨大的一部分。我们正是带着这种认知进入这个行业的，我们也希望这样做——我们想要帮助他人，无论是否有这种认可，我想是的。而且，你知道的，
it goes beyond you know you mentioned the, but it goes beyond that as well. We've got to be making sure that we are speaking respectfully about our clients, even when they're not in the room. I think having been part of teams, it can be easy to slip into colloquialisms or less than respectful ways of talking about clients or clients' families. And it is a reminder, isn't it, that that integrity runs through all of our interactions when we are wearing our lanyard, you know. And for that matter, when we're not, you know, we've got the integrity to uphold the NHS values, even when we're going about our day-to-day lives, you know. And, you know, there's all the separate conversation,
这不仅仅局限于——你刚才提到了这一点，但它远不止于此。我们必须确保我们在谈论客户时保持尊重，即使他们不在房间里。我想，作为团队的一员，人们很容易陷入使用俗语或不太尊重的方言来谈论客户或客户家属的习惯。这是一个提醒，不是吗？当我们挂着工作证时，这种正直贯穿于我们所有的互动之中。不仅如此，当我们不戴工作证时，你知道的，我们也有责任维护NHS的价值观，即使在我们进行日常生活时也是如此。而且，你知道的，这又是另一个话题了，
but all the kind of what you should and shouldn't be seen doing when you're wearing a lanyard or even when you are on social media and you've tagged that you work for the NHS. And I think if I could go follow this up a little bit, you just said about using colloquialisms, it made me think of something in my experience. if I could go follow this up a little bit, you just said about using colloquialisms, it made me think of something in my experience. The role of psychology, whether it's assistants or psychologists, I have found is quite well respected in NHS fields, and it's getting more and more respect, which is great, because we need it. But with that respect, the whole Ben Parker,
但关于你戴着工作证时应该做什么、不应该做什么，甚至当你使用社交媒体并标注你在NHS工作时，都有相应的规范。我想如果我能顺着这个话题再多说一点，你刚才提到使用俗语，让我想起了我经历中的一件事。如果我能顺着这个话题再多说一点，你刚才提到使用俗语，让我想起了我经历中的一件事。我发现心理学角色的地位——无论是助理还是心理学家——在NHS领域都受到了相当高的尊重，而且这种尊重与日俱增，这太棒了，因为我们需要它。但伴随着这种尊重，就像本·帕克所说的那样，
great responsibilities, with great power comes responsibility and so forth. And with all that respect we are given, we should remember to do the things you've just mentioned, to uphold the values, to uphold the ethics that we do so believe in, that are all sort of embodied in everything we are doing to try and help others. And with that extra respect and responsibility we're given, we can kind of stand up and say actually to staff, nurses, whoever it may be, let's not talk about them like that. Let's keep it professional.
能力越大，责任越大，诸如此类。带着我们所获得的所有的尊重，我们应该记住去做你刚才提到的那些事情，去维护那些我们深信不疑的价值观和道德规范，这些都体现在我们为帮助他人所做的一切努力中。带着我们被赋予的这份额外的尊重和责任，我们可以挺身而出，对工作人员、护士或其他任何人说：“嘿，我们不要那样谈论他们。让我们保持专业。”
And in my experience, when that's happened, I haven't been kind of shunned away it's kind of like oh yeah they're right they're right because for better or for worse the the fact that psychology is so well known in the in popular sort of science popular world that does bring with it a bit of cachet and a bit of respect that we can use to our advantage at times and and it's also what makes it feel so in my experience it's what make it feel makes it feel so hard when we do feel exploited when we don't have the right support behind us because we think you know we are an important role for the patients and for the team so yeah I think it's a really good point and and really useful to to use your son as an example there.
在我的经验中，当这种情况发生时，我并没有被排斥，而是会得到这样的回应：“哦，是的，他们是对的，他们是对的。”因为不管好坏，心理学在公众认知和流行科学领域如此广为人知，这确实带来了一点声望和尊重，有时我们可以利用这一点来为自己谋利。这也是为什么在我的经验中，当我们感到被剥削、背后没有得到正确支持时，会让人觉得如此艰难，因为我们认为，对于患者和团队而言，我们扮演着重要的角色。所以，是的，我认为这是一个非常好的观点，用你的儿子作为例子真的很有用。
Absolutely. You know, I feel like I'm doing a good enough job. You know, that's about as much as I have capacity for. I think that's all we need. It's all we need as parents. It needs to be good enough. It doesn't need to be exceptional. And maybe my good enough is exceptional for them. don't know like a whole other conversation anyway I'm just
绝对的。你知道，我觉得我做得已经足够好了。你知道，这就是我目前能力所及的极限。我认为这就是我们所需要的全部。作为父母，这就是我们所需要的一切。只需要“足够好”就行，不需要做到出类拔萃。也许我所认为的“足够好”，对他们来说就已经是非凡的了。不知道……不管怎样，这又是另一个话题了。我只是
conscious of time are there any other points that you want to kind of draw or bring forward before we close Luke I suppose just from the guidance, it mentioned reflective practice. And I would have liked to have seen a bit more about that because it is so huge in our discipline. So it's good that it's there, but they went in quite detail with regards to supervision, which I was really pleasantly surprised with. But they didn't leave much for reflection or reflexive practice and the difference between those two things so that would be a gripe of mine that maybe they could increase or improve in the future yeah it felt like it had been dropped in as a as a buzz phrase but there wasn't there wasn't
考虑到时间关系，卢克，在我们结束之前，还有没有其他你想提出或分享的观点？卢克：我想，从指南本身来看，它提到了反思性实践。我本希望看到更多关于这方面的内容，因为它在我们的学科中占据着如此重要的地位。所以它能出现在里面很好，但他们在督导方面进行了相当深入的探讨，这让我感到非常惊喜。然而，他们并没有留出太多篇幅来探讨反思、反身性实践以及这两者之间的区别，这可能会成为我的一个槽点，也许他们未来可以增加或改进这一点。是的，感觉它就像是被当作一个流行热词随手塞进去的，但并没有
much legwork put into what that looks like and I think it would have been really nice um to have I've had some case study examples about what what is good practice and what isn't good practice and you know what what are your options if you find yourself in x y and z but maybe that is a maybe that is this is very much a recruitment document it's not necessarily hugely useful for someone that happens to find themselves in that role. True. Well, I still think that's a great, great idea, actually, because even for recruitment teams, it would be good to see what is a good, what is an intermediate or medium example and what is a bad example for recruitment and for the actual people trying to get their job
花太多功夫去探讨它具体是什么样子的。我觉得如果能有一些案例研究示例，展示什么是良好的实践、什么是不良实践，以及如果你发现自己陷入这样那样的困境时有什么选择，那会非常棒。但也许这——也许这在很大程度上只是一份招聘文件，对于恰好处于那个角色的人来说，它不一定有那么大的实用价值。确实。不过，我仍然认为这是一个非常棒的主意，实际上，因为即使对招聘团队来说，能够看到什么是优秀、中等或一般的招聘示范案例，以及求职者该如何应对，也是很有价值的。
so I think that's a great great idea and you know maybe maybe someone's listening to this and and they'll take your idea forward I hope they do or maybe I'll just do it like that's also an option just before we finished I realized that we haven't covered what much of the guidance has been put together from. And it's from a relatively smallish research study done by the BPS where they sampled people who identify as a citizen psychologist who are British Psychological Society members. And the number of respondents for that was 337 so 337 but of that it gave us some insight into demographics and you kind of observed that actually initially you thought that some of the the demographics were changing and gave you a little bit of hope for the future but yeah like it's hard to it's hard to tell with it being a small sample, but also that it's limited to only BPS members, of course,
所以我认为这是一个绝妙的主意，也许有人正在听这期节目，并会把你的创意付诸实践。我希望如此，或者也许我自己就会这么做，这也是一个选项。在我们结束之前，我意识到我们还没有讨论这份指南的大部分内容是基于什么研究得出的。它来自英国心理学会（BPS）开展的一项规模相对较小的研究，他们的调查对象是自认为是心理学公民且身为英国心理学会会员的人。调查的受访者总共有337人，也就是337位。但从这些数据中，我们得以一窥人口统计数据，你之前也观察到，实际上你最初认为某些人口统计数据正在发生变化，这让你对未来看到了一丝希望。但话说回来，
because it might be certain people that are more likely to be members. But, you know, of this, they also were sampling how often people were getting supervision. I think it was something like nine people were not getting any at all. Just like, oh, that is awful, isn isn't it that it brings it into stark reality yeah um i think it's really
因为样本量很小，很难下定论，而且它仅限于BPS会员，当然，因为某些人群更有可能成为会员。不过，在这项调查中，他们还抽样调查了人们接受督导的频率。我记得似乎有9个人完全没有接受任何督导。当时的感觉就是：“天哪，这太糟糕了，不是吗？”这把人拉回了残酷的现实中。是的，嗯，我觉得看到背后的统计数据真的很好，有一些很好的数据。但正如你所说，从宏观角度来看，这个样本非常小。而且，我想我注意到了社会经济状况正在发生变化，然而当我阅读底部的星号说明、也就是参考注释时，上面说他们实际上创建了自己的指标。他们获取了数据，然后对数据进行了后处理，
good to see statistics behind it some some some good data but as you say it's very small in the grand scheme of things and um i think i'd noticed some of the socio-economics were shifting however then when i read the asterisks at the bottom, the reference, I suppose, it said that they had kind of created their own metrics. They'd taken the data and then they'd post data. They'd created three metrics to loosely be placed upon different metrics of the working class, middle class and maybe lower middle class or something. So even that in itself is a little bit loose so i don't know how much it is actually changing um so it would be good to see more robust statistics wider maybe reach out to people who have worked in the profession
创建了三个大致对应工人阶级、中产阶级以及可能还有下中产阶级等不同阶层的指标。所以即使是这一点本身也有些松散，我不知道这种情况到底改变了多少。因此，看到更强有力、样本更广泛的统计数据会很好，也许可以把范围扩大到已经在行业中工作的、而不仅仅是AP（助理心理学家）群体。我不太确定，但能看到一些统计数据总是好的，只是我不知道这些数据能说明多大问题。是的，嗯。听到你谈论星号，我丈夫说我特别喜欢小字注释。如果我在看电视时看到广告，上面说“67%的人更喜欢这个”或者诸如此类的话，然后上面说“这款睫毛膏太棒了，会改变你的睫毛”，接着我就会说：“看，这里有个星号，上面写着这个广告使用了假睫毛！”我就会感到十分愤怒，而他甚至根本没有注意到那个星号，只是让广告信息从他脑海中滑过。而我会说：“不，这不公平，这不对！
um and we are qualified now as opposed to just aps um i'm not sure but it's good to get some stats but i don't know how far we can take it yeah um hearing you speak about asterisks my husband says that I I love small print like if I'm watching tv and there's an advert and it says like 67 percent of people preferred this or you know yada yada yada and then it says this mascara is amazing it's going to change your lashes and then I'm like there's asterisks and it says this advert is filled with lash inserts I'm like I'm outraged and he's not even noticed the asterisk so just he's kind of letting it flow over him I'm like no it's not fair it's not right no we have we have to find out where our numbers come from because statistics can be manipulated
嗯，我们现在已经是正式心理学家了，而不仅仅是助理心理学家，嗯，我不确定，但能了解一些统计数据是很好的，不过我不知道我们能把这推到什么程度。是的，嗯，听到你谈到星号，我丈夫说我我喜欢看小字。比如我在看电视时，有一个广告说“67%的人更喜欢这个”或者诸如此类的话，然后它说这款睫毛膏太棒了，它会改变你的睫毛，然后我就说：‘这里有个星号，上面写着这个广告里使用了假睫毛插入物。’我说：‘我太生气了！’而他甚至都没有注意到那个星号，所以他就只是让它随风飘过，而我说：‘不，这不公平，这不对！’不，我们必须弄清楚我们的数字是从哪里来的，因为统计数据是可以被操纵的
and used and when you read that the asterisk at the bottom, you're like, oh, it's not actually that significant really, is it? So I can use the data, but it's not really saying what I think it's saying. Absolutely. The worst offender is when you're watching shampoo and conditioner adverts and it says versus unconditioned hair. And it's like, have i bought myself a really cheap conditioner from
并被利用的。当你读到最底部的星号时，你会想，哦，其实并没有那么重要，对吧？所以我可以使用这些数据，但它其实并不是在说我以为它在说的事情。绝对是的。最糟糕的罪魁祸首就是当你看着洗发水和护发素的广告，上面写着“与未护理的头发相比”。这就好像，我给自己买了一款来自
you know the cheapest brand i could find i may have similar results to this because you know i'm not gonna not condition my long hair like so yeah it's you know we can skew the stats however we want can't we i guess this is the gift and the curse of viewing things analytically. Indeed it is. Luke it's been an absolute pleasure speaking with you again and I was like let's keep this about half an hour but it's just it's such a big and important topic that we've not managed that at all have we but yeah I think these are really helpful and interesting conversations to have yeah thank you very thank you loads marianne it's been good to chat again um glad you're
你知道的，我能找到的最便宜的品牌的非常便宜的护发素，我可能会得到与此类似的结果，因为你知道的，我不会不给我的长发使用护发素，所以，是的，你知道的，我们可以随心所欲地扭曲统计数据，不是吗？我想这就是用分析的眼光看待事物的天赋与诅咒吧。确实如此。卢克，能再次与你交谈绝对是我的荣幸，我本来想说让我们把时间控制在大约半小时，但这是一个如此重大且重要的话题，我们根本没有做到这一点，不是吗？不过，是的，我认为这些是非常有帮助且有趣的对话。是的，非常感谢，非常感谢你，玛丽安，很高兴再次与你聊天，嗯，很高兴你
recovering from your surgery recently you look great you look very well see you're very active on linkedin and to your point it is important we have these conversations because i think if i'd have stumbled across these things a few years ago, it would have been really, really helpful. So hopefully it helps some in the industry. Yeah, absolutely. Thank you. Yeah, so I've been quite vocal on my social media with the fact that I'd had a mole removed just last week, actually, and had to wear this big bandage for a week so I am had my stitches removed on Monday and we are we are talking currently on a Wednesday it's a Wednesday today isn't it so yeah it's been it's been a really interesting process actually and kind of I
最近手术后正在康复，你看上去气色很好，状态很不错。看到你在领英上非常活跃，而且正如你所说，我们进行这些对话非常重要，因为我想如果几年前我偶然发现了这些东西，那将会非常非常有用。所以希望这能对行业内的一些人有所帮助。是的，绝对的。谢谢。是的，我在社交媒体上相当直言不讳地谈到我上周刚刚切除了一颗痣的事实，实际上不得不戴这个大绷带一个星期，所以我在周一拆了线，而我们目前是在周三进行交谈，今天是周三，对吧？所以，是的，这实际上是一个非常有趣的过程，而且某种程度上我
decided to start talking about it from a from a health anxiety public health perspective because so many of us don't go to the doctors with changes that we've noticed in ourselves and obviously I hope that it will have a really good outcome for me but this might just change somebody else's outcome if they see me talking about it yeah absolutely and I think it will because I've been in similar positions where I've had sort of surgeries for health reasons and I've tried to cover certain things up and but I you know just thought it doesn't really matter that much I'm healthy I'm trying my best and and that is what you're trying to do which is which is really important thanks Luke thanks so much for your time and also before we finish you've been able to do this in
决定开始从健康焦虑和公共卫生视角来谈论它，因为我们当中有很多人在自己身上注意到变化时并没有去看医生，当然我希望这会对我有很好的结果，但如果他们看到我谈论它，这可能会改变其他人的结果。是的，绝对的，我想会的，因为我也曾处于类似的境地，当时我因健康原因做过某种手术，我曾试图掩盖某些事情，但我，你知道的，只是觉得这其实没那么重要，我很健康，我在尽我最大的努力，而这正是你正在努力去做的事情，这真的非常重要。谢谢你，卢克，非常感谢你抽出时间。另外，在我们结束之前，你能够利用
your work time because of another bit of guidance that suggests that we ought to be able to spend is it 3.75 hours per week whole time equivalent on continuing professional development which might include something like this or going to a research meeting or maybe even listening to aspiring psychologists podcast episodes I don't know like but you should have CPD in your role yes I am going to milk it a lot and say you know this is part of my 3.7 did you say 3.5 hours yeah I think it was 3.75 hours I think whole time equivalent I think the other hour or so I will be listening to the aspiring psychologist podcast well thank you very much I'd say other podcasts are available, but I don't really know that they are.
你的工作时间来做这件事，是因为另一项指导意见建议，我们应该能够每周花（你是说3.75小时吗？全职工作当量）来进行持续专业发展（CPD），这可能包括像这样的活动、参加研究会议，或者甚至听《有志向的心理学家》播客节目，我不知道，诸如此类，但在你的角色中，你应该有CPD时间。是的，我要好好利用这一点，并说“你知道的，这是我的3.75部分——你刚才说的是3.5小时吗？”是的，我想那是3.75小时，我想是全职工作当量。我想另外一个小时左右我会用来听《有志向的心理学家》播客。好的，非常感谢。我会说还有其他播客可供选择，但我其实并不确定是否真的有。
Thanks so much for your time, Luke. And please don't be a stranger and let me know if I can help with anything in the future. Thank you, Marion. Yes, I will do, definitely. Who knows, hopefully be back on one day. For the next stage of your journey, that would be marvellous. Thank you. Thanks, Luke. Thank you once again to our guest, Luke Meakin. What an absolute pleasure it is to speak with him. If you haven't yet caught our previous episodes, it's episode 148, wherever you get your podcasts. Or as I said, on YouTube, it is the one that was launched in October
非常感谢你抽出时间，卢克。请不要见外，如果以后有什么我可以帮忙的，请随时告诉我。谢谢你，玛丽安。好的，我会的，一定的。谁知道呢，希望有一天能再来。为了你旅程的下一阶段，那将是极好的。谢谢。谢谢你，卢克。再次感谢我们的嘉宾卢克·米金。与他交谈绝对是一种荣幸。如果你还没听过我们之前的剧集，那是第148集，无论你在哪里收听播客都可以找到。或者正如我所说，在YouTube上，那是10月份发布的
called What is an Assistant Psychologist and What Do They Do? If you don't already subscribe to the channel, please do take a moment to do so. If you don't already follow the show on your podcast platform of choice, please do. It's the kindest thing you can do for free for any podcaster. Please do take a moment to rate and review if you are listening on Apple Podcasts and on Spotify. You can rate as well. Come and let me know what you think to this episode on the free Facebook group The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Marianne Trent. Do consider whether the books The Aspiring Psychologist Collective and The Clinical Psychologist Collective might be really useful for your
名为《什么是助理心理学家以及他们做什么？》的那一集。如果你还没有订阅这个频道，请花一点时间订阅。如果你还没有在你选择的播客平台上关注这个节目，请关注一下。这是你可以免费为任何播客做的心意最好的事。如果你正在苹果播客上收听，请花一点时间进行评分和评论。在Spotify上，你也可以进行评分。快来在免费的Facebook群组“由玛丽安·特伦特博士创建的有志向的心理学家社群”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Marianne Trent）中让我知道你对这一集的看法吧。请考虑一下《有志向的心理学家合集》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）和《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这两本书是否对你的
journey and they do get beautiful reviews. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step and you love conversations like this and you love getting to know qualified psychologists that can help you with the next step of your journey, please do consider checking out the Aspiring Psychologist membership which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum the next episode of this podcast will be available from 10 a.m on saturdays on youtube and from 6 a.m on mondays wherever you get your podcast thank you so much for being part of my take care then let this be your guide
旅程非常有帮助，它们确实获得了极好的评价。如果现在是你的时间，你已经准备好迈出下一步，并且你热爱这样的对话，热爱结识能够帮助你迈出旅程下一步的合格心理学家，请考虑查看“有志向的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），你只需每月30英镑起即可加入，且无最低期限。本播客的下一集将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，并于周一上午6点在你获取播客的任何平台上发布。非常感谢你成为我节目的一部分，多保重，让这成为你的指南
with this podcast that you'll find you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist
通过这个播客，你会发现你正在通往获得资格的道路上，这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志向的心理学家播客》。我叫加娜（Jana），我是一名见习心理健康从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现其中关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣
it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这让我惊叹于通往那里的途径竟然有这么多，而且没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我充满信心，认为“不，我没有做错”，并减轻了我的压力。因此，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始阅读，你就不会把书放下了。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。